greed island the rarest video game in
the world was released in 1987.
meanwhile gone freaks was a sperm
released in 1986 released from his
father and into his mother that is
unless it isn't today i'm going to take
you through one of the wildest secrets
in hunter hunter because gohan's mother
doesn't exist and jing made gone using
nine hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for highly improbable
births my name is liam and to the best
of my knowledge i was created without
men my birth was more the how shall we
say traditional mix of bodily functions
but for as long as jing has been gone
and gone has been after jing one
paramount question has reigned supreme
who exactly is mama freaks the theories
about this are absolutely endless some
people say that gone's mother came from
the dark continent whilst others say
that she was a completely random
everyday woman with no importance
whatsoever and there's even a
particularly disturbing albeit kind of
hilarious theory that paristan is gone's
mother and his current duel with jing is
more of a parental spat we're going to
ignore that in fact we're going to
ignore all of those because the answer
is perfectly spelled out in the series
itself and it has been for about a
decade unlike jing mama gone didn't even
have the chance to become gone because
she never existed to begin with and the
answer to this riddle is revealed via
greed island read island was introduced
as a digital game whereby super special
nen users could travel inside and play
however it was later revealed to be a
real-life nan game taking place on a
real-life island functioning on what has
to be the most complex series of nen
vows and restrictions that this series
has ever seen but greed island is like a
nen playground where anyone can make
anything happen so long as they have the
cards to do so that is cards they're
very important and greed island features
three main card types restricted cards
unrestricted cards and spell cards the
arc itself mostly focuses on the latter
you'll be familiar with cards like a
company for example which were used into
oblivion so it was more or less hunters
using these spells in conjunction with
their own abilities the next type of
card are the unrestricted ones and they
are optional and generally quite common
things or creatures that players can
pick up such as the illustrious rock and
its evolved form large rock these didn't
get used a lot because
quite frankly they're more or less
useless however the third type of card
the restricted cards grant supreme
abilities these cards provide powers
that rival and in some cases completely
outclass actual nun abilities held by
hunter hunt characters however the
problem is that to complete the greed
island game players need all 99 of these
cards in their binder which naturally
means that the players of the game don't
actually use these cards because they
need them and i know i'm talking a lot
about fictional game mechanics but this
is important because it holds a very
profound answer but first this video is
sponsored by monster legends a
free-to-play mobile game available on
all of the devices here you can collect
over 900 monsters with varying elements
and rarities to build your own
monsterific empire and of course you'll
need stuff to do the building like say
food and gold in order to grow you can
breed your monsters mixing different
elements into a new species that hatches
baby monsters which go on to evolve and
level up with the help of runes relics
and talents which you can use to create
the best team and challenge your friends
to a round of battle combat and one of
the super unique features of this game
is the youtuber island here you can find
various monsters created in
collaboration with the biggest of
youtubers who isn't on me definitely not
me but more along the lines of the
legends of say mr beast and dream you
can download the game using my link in
the description or qr code and when you
do there will be a special free starter
pack containing the ever so exclusive
fire habitat with three epic monsters
being the volcano keepers helberos fires
and salamander make sure you download
the game now and claim your free starter
pack which will help you get a head
start and speed your leveling process so
do that thing but for now it's back to
you me greed island has a series of what
i would label strange restricted cards
such as mad scientist pheromones the
effect of which is spray on your body to
attract the opposite sex however you
cannot adjust the strength so be careful
as it may cause a proliferation of
stalkers or liquor spring which says
draw some of this springs water one hour
later it will become a random alcoholic
drink of exquisite taste and
extraordinary quality and i just get the
feeling that that was 100 a jing choice
he strikes me as the kind of guy who
might get a little bit too friendly with
alcohol but also these restricted cards
can encroach into more creepy territory
for example connections have ring
scissors which says cut a picture of
someone you don't want to see with these
scissors and you will never see them
again caution it will affect everyone in
the picture except yourself which sounds
like the entire premise of a horror film
but i guess the idea is that jin created
these restricted 99 superpowers as a
prize for the winner you know you beat
the game select three super powers and
these they can do just about anything
including create life the first tier of
our gone inside kick is a card called
pregnancy stone the effect of which is
carry a stone weighing three kilos each
for one month and you will get pregnant
even if you're male you may choose the
sex of the baby by the female or male
stone and that is a pretty big thing i
mean men can do all kinds of wonderful
wacky and kind of scary things but to
actually create life is that is a whole
new level of power and i think i think
you know where we're going with this
jing used this card to make himself
pregante this resulted in a baby gone
being born on may 5th 1987 the very same
year that this babymaking game would be
released anna it sounds like a joke and
i thought this was ridiculous at first
as well i really did but i am telling
you there is so much more to this
firstly when it comes to creating life
we are no stranger to none abilities
playing god i mean in the series nen
users can create objects enhance or
manipulate people emit life force and
even transmute any element imaginable
even those that don't exist like a
certain bungee gun and children's
chewables aside these are the very
building blocks of life and where we do
see very blatant examples of men
creating life is with the nen beasts
some of them are hollow shell puppets
controlled by their users others are
beasts programmed to act or respond to
certain conditions but some go a step
further having their own individual
personalities and in later stages of
hunter hunter nen beasts exist who
operate completely independently of
their users in fact in the case of the
guardian spirit beasts their users don't
even know that they exist so we're
practically already there when it comes
to creating life we just haven't done so
perfectly mimicking a human unless it's
without you which does perfectly mimic a
human and that's the whole thing it does
but you get what i mean because nen
isn't magic in fact nen isn't anything
nen is just the name of the art form
what we're actually doing here is
wielding aura and aura is life force so
if there is anything capable of creating
life then surely life energy seems like
a pretty legit candidate so how does
jing make baby because your pregnancy
stone can make someone pegnate even if
they are biologically male but then
there's still the uh the problem of
evicting the baby because if
biologically male bodies were commercial
buildings and let's just say we would be
severely fined for not having the
appropriate fire exits but don't worry
because jing thought of this as well and
created another of the 99 restricted
cards called hormone cookies which says
after eating this candy your sex will
temporarily change for 24 hours a set of
10 boxes 20 cookies per box now for
those of you who are interested in the
maths that is 200 cookies as a whole so
you have quite a bit of room to maneuver
i mean a standard pregnancy is 280 days
which yes is more than the cookies we
have to cover but i'm going to assume
that in this magical fictional world we
could just carry the baby and pop a
cookie right before giving birth that'll
just redo whatever the quest is to get
another cookie card the point is that
jing giving birth as weird as it sounds
is shockingly possible one thing we
should point out is that jing is not a
game master he's a player like everyone
else and it's entirely possible that if
gone were born on greed island that the
game may not allow him to travel outside
of its boundaries but i mean that again
it also might jut gone being a living
breathing human it might just register
him as a player and that's why gone has
his own save fire but assuming that this
endeavor had to be completed in reality
to allow gone the freedom of a real boy
then it's pretty easily done through the
concept of the prize binder which allows
players to take three cards outside of
the greed island borders to use however
they'd like so jing playtests his game
because what dev doesn't he manages to
beat it attain the prize binder and
select three cards pregnancy stone
hormone cookie and the third card which
is probably the most mind-blowing of all
have you ever wondered why jing has such
a such a bit of a weird thing going on
with pandas during the chairman election
after boozing jing was scheduled for an
interview however he of course did not
show up and a seemingly stuffed panda
was popped up there in his place funny
joke he wasn't there so he improvised
with what we had and what we had as a
panda so the panda is now jing except
that this happens again during a zodiac
meeting where jing is absent his chair
is taken up by this very same panda at
which point it becomes pretty clear that
this is not a choice made by the zodiacs
this panda stuffed or not is jing's
representative because why would the
zodiacs choose a panda jing's assigned
animal as a boss so surely they'd use a
boar instead but everything becomes much
clearer when we posit that the third and
final car jing took from greed island
was panda made a creature described as
very neat and loves to cook each has a
hobby such as sewing or gardening they
are excellent at taking care of human
children very convenient because jing is
completely unexcellent at taking care of
human children and right now we're just
assuming that this is some sort of cute
stuffed panda but it could very easily
be a living breathing nun beast i mean
for crap's sake this is a series where
we have a living breathing bean man so
anything is possible but if the panda is
stuffed then weirdly enough that would
only make this idea more solid because
the timeline of events would go like
this jing starts developing greed island
and either before or along the way he
decides to procreate on a whim he
specifically caters the greed island
mechanics to allow for this play tests
the game and takes these three cards
with him back to reality pregnancy stone
and hormone cookies allow him to carry a
child and give birth and panda made was
intended to raise gon in lieu of actual
parenting however panda made fails due
to some sort of bad n-coding or perhaps
a time limit and instead becomes a
stuffed toy so jing now thoroughly
screwed instead of taking his child
around the world with a panda bear
taking care of him has no choice but to
dump gone on whale island inevitably to
be raised by mito and from there we know
the story jing gave some bs about
separating with gone's mother then mita
amito did a lot of yelling and took full
custody of gone and in doing so mito
became gone's true mother she stepped
into a role that did not exist and
that's why gone has no interest at all
in listening to jing reveal the truth
because on a primal level he knows that
there is really nothing to find out and
that mito was his mother all along even
then you know it might still sound a bit
weird i mean why would togashi do
something so left field like have his
protagonist be born from a game well
this is actually one of togashi's more
consistent features this man has always
been a fiend for games specifically
anything rpg related in fact in 1987 he
wrote a short story called tonder
birthday present which is about a middle
school student bringing his favorite rpg
to life with his mad scientist father
and then there's that year again 1987.
again gone's birth here and the year the
greed island was released also in level
e togashi constructs an entire rock
where grade schoolers are transported to
an alien planet that lives exactly like
a final fantasy style rpg oh and he's
also notorious for playing like insane
amounts of dragon quest instead of
actually drawing manga but games are
closer to dogashi's heart than probably
any other theme explored in his works so
to have his main protagonist quite
literally be born from a game may be
very out of character with your standard
shonen author however when it comes to
togashi it's one of those things that
just makes sense especially since as
hunter hunt went on it very deliberately
proceeded counter to typical shonen
trends and the reason why this isn't
spelled out is blatantly to us like
having killer say something like gone i
killer have put the pieces together and
i know the true truth of your mother
that doesn't happen because oh gosh he
doesn't care he doesn't want to play
that standard boring game however the
clues he did leave behind paint a very
compelling men portrait a portrait of a
man with unparalleled power and fickle
interest like creating a child on a whim
then leaving his whole game as a
playground for that child to grow learn
and well play in at least by the freaks
definition of the word play which is
probably the same as the zoldic and
netro definition as well to be honest
and i will say that yes this is an
outrageously crazy theory thing and i
myself do find it hard to believe simply
because i don't know if togashi would
care enough to purposely plant all of
those seeds however i do find it much
more plausible than its sister theory
which states that jing used hormone
cookies to change his sex and then
invoked mad scientist pheromones to
attract a partner like say razer or the
ever popular paristan so yeah the
haunted phantom gets it gets a bit weird
and thanks again to monster legends for
sponsoring this video